hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today I have
Katie here with me because it is
Administrative Professionals Day and she
is my administrative professional so I
just wanted to have her on and say thank
you thank you very much she's awesome
and she handles all of my travel
arrangements when I want to go to
conferences and does a great job because
I don't understand how all that credit
card system works here there's a lot of
paperwork also she's awesome she's like
right outside my door her desk is right
there so she can hear me streaming and
she's super fun and nice so thank you
thanks Jesse I've been listening to the
show now for a year outside of his door
I feel like I've learned a lot and I
could meet me do some coding but I
really couldn't oh you can do it but I
got a nice plant from everybody that I
think I could keep alive I'm really hard
it doesn't look nice yeah a geranium
which likes Sun and water so I don't
know I'm gonna try but it's beautiful so
Jesse works with a good team here he's
smart when he shows up she works from
home a lot so we don't get to see him or
sometimes he'll be in here for hours and
then he'll have his door closed and we
won't even know he's here
so what he does emerge she's alright yes
you want to say to YouTube No thank you
for watching me I feel like a star even
though I've been on
for 30 seconds so all right do your
thing Jesse awesome thanks hi everybody
all right so yeah so Katie is really
awesome and she was a good sport about
coming on coming on the show and yes you
don't get to see my the rest of my team
here but we do we have Katie and Bryan
Sizemore is also he works as a developer
as well and he's just an awesome guy and
my boss Tom and Liz doesn't work
directly with the programming but she
works on a lot of our marketing
campaigns there's just so many awesome
people in our department we got video
people photographers graphic designers
writers so there's a lot of other people
that provide content and support for
what I'm doing so it's just it's kind of
cool maybe I'll make more of an effort
to get them involved but since today was
Administrative Professionals Day I
thought I'd bring Katie on and all right
so let's get started today's gonna be a
little bit different than normal because
we're gonna work on an old site I try to
do like more new stuff we try to keep
their packages up-to-date we even use
some beta stuff but I need to make an
update to something I build about two
years ago so I thought I'd start right
from the beginning and I'll go through
cloning the repo installing all the
packages and starting it up and that may
be helpful for those of you that are new
to github and get-and looks like we have
someone new
vish Vishakha vishakha welcome let me
know if I'm not pronouncing that right
so just join tree code camp about a week
ago and I'm already in love it's awesome
oh so glad you like it and I'm glad
you're you're watching so you know see a
lot of other
people are saying hello so yeah so we're
gonna do if you're new to the stream
which there are some new people here I
break things up and I do 25 minutes of
coding where I kind of talk through what
I'm doing and then I take five minutes
and I answer questions in the chat we do
another 25 minutes of coding and then at
the end the whole rest of the stream is
dedicated to question an answer and so
if you have any questions please put
them in but be patient I will get to all
the questions eventually let's see
robot Villa says hi and that is let's
see I believe robot Villa is the company
of I can't remember if you don't mind
look what was your name I know because I
saw you on the mom scan code thing and I
follow you on Twitter and Instagram
why am i blanking out anyway thanks for
watching
Francesca that's it for in Cheska
alright so sorry I can't believe I
forgot your name I see your stuff all
the time
alright cool Harshit in here all right
let's get this let's get started with
this and then I'll come back to the chat
so let me show you my screen and you can
see I'm starting out with just my
terminal right so I'm in my projects
folder and I want to get this project
which I'll bring over I want to get this
project onto my computer so you can see
most of this was from two years ago I
have made some minor updates since then
I want to go to the clone button and I
want to just copy
I have my SSH key set up so I copy this
if you don't have your SSH keys then
you'll want to use the HTTP link and my
github looks dark in the background this
is just a theme that I have running on
top of the regular github so don't worry
if yours doesn't look exactly like this
to us it is here hey Anna how's it going
and Jeff asked if we were gonna do an
grok today I'm not gonna do that grow up
today because the site I'm working on
you have to have a login for so even if
I shared it with you you'd still need a
login so it wouldn't really work so oops
forget a step let's go we need to do git
clone so you have to have git installed
on your machine already which I did do a
video about installing get in cloning a
repo so if you want to check out like
how to do that the video is on my
youtube channel the link is in the
description so we do a git clone and
then I paste in that that address that I
just got from github and we hit answer
and now while those really fast so
really really fast so now we should have
a folder called fus bulletin in our
projects folder so let's do an LS just
to see everything and we'll see if fu s
bulletin so now we're gonna change
directory CD into fu s bulletin and
we're gonna do I'm gonna open this in
Visual Studio code so if you have the
command line stuff setup for Visual
Studio code you can just type in code
and then in this case I'm just gonna
type a period and that's gonna open up
everything in this folder in Visual
Studio code
so after this opens up we'll be able to
see our folder structure and we're gonna
go into
let's go to our package.json first just
get an idea of what we're using in this
project so we had to have this running
with gulp so gulps not quite as popular
as it used to be everybody's using
webpack now but you may remember gulp
and let's see we are using some babel
stuff so we're able to use some of the
newer things and looks like we're
deploying this with flight plan awesome
so not really a very complex project and
actually I can update this because
so it's really hard to type and talk at
the same time so evidently I copied like
the starter for this project from a
previous project and I never bothered to
change the package.json so we'll change
that now that'll be one of our changes
now our next step is going to be to
actually load these packages and this
was so far back that I hadn't even used
yarn yet
so you notice investment projects I use
yarn instead of NPM and I want to view
the integrated terminal so we could do
it all right here in one screen so if
you are using visual studio code this is
a super useful tool I want to split this
as well because we're gonna run where I
can actually run it in one screen once
we get this going so let's do NPM oops
NPM install that's going to install all
these packages and the dependencies for
all of those packages and it's gonna put
it in a folder it's going to be called a
node modules so we'll see that appear
soon and then we're gonna be ready to
run the project locally and start
working on it it looks like it's my
audio out of sync with the video it
looks like it to me okay now it looks
now it looks okay again it looked like
it went out of sync for a second okay
cool yeah let me know if I had some
problems yesterday but that was on a
different machine with the audio and
video getting out of sync all right so
you can see this is the one it's thing
sometimes it takes longer than others
depending on how many packages and what
packages you're bringing in
and wow that's going I'm gonna go to the
chat just so we make good use of our
time and I'm going to look through the
chat see if there's any questions I can
answer while we're waiting
Tobi's has just signed up two weeks ago
awesome awesome I hope your you're
enjoying free code camp and thanks for
watching the stream as well oh cool
Harshit who is in the himalayas as the
time is 7 p.m. there so it's a good time
to stream Michael said I missed the
intro who was that if you missed the
intro you can always go back and watch
it again but I had one of my co-workers
Katie here for the intro so if you
didn't catch that you can go back and
catch it's just the first you know maybe
two or three minutes of the stream
john doe's said can a newbie do this
knowing nothing about coding I'm gonna
do my best to explain everything so if
you feel like it's a little bit beyond
what you can do now you still may be
able to get something out of this dream
you know ask questions and you may be
able to pick something up I will say
though for this dream when I built this
I used you know the techniques that I
knew best at the time that was two years
ago so even if it was cutting edge two
years ago which I don't even think it
was cutting edge then it it's still
outdated today so the techniques and
things that I use to solve problems will
still be helpful no matter what but I
don't think like the actual code and
stuff may be a good example of what to
do
alright it looks like it worked so you
see now we have our node modules folder
which has lots of stuff in there so so
awesome that NPM which is node package
manager handles all this for us can you
imagine having to manually load all this
stuff it would make me not want to do
this job I had to do that for every
project so that's in there and we should
be able to use gulp watch I believe
that's the command yep all right gulp
watch so now it'll say that we can view
our projects locally at localhost 3012
soar 3012 so let's try that out you know
let me move we move some things around
so we get a better idea what's what's
going on okay and it already opened for
us so I think we can
well I mean okay so let me show you what
what exactly we're going to be changing
and if we see anything that's weird
along the way we can change that we can
refactor depending on how much time that
we have but right now we have these
categories and we need an extra category
here so it's it's going to be a somewhat
of a basic change but we also need to
make sure that our data gets categorized
properly as well so we're going to I
guess temporarily miss categorize
something just to make sure we can get
it to show up so this is actually
pulling the live data from a wordpress
installation we're using the WordPress
API for that even though this is you
know our local version this project by
the way is a private repo so that's why
I did not include a link to the code and
we have worked on a react version of
this before we just didn't finish it so
once we finish that we'll be replacing
this old jQuery version with react and
so we're just to you know give you a
visual and what we're gonna do we'll be
working in this area now let's go to the
code and let's go at our app one good
thing to know if you ever get like a
premade project structure don't do any
work directly in the dist folder make
sure you're doing it in the app folder
or you know whatever other folder but
just not dist I once made a mistake when
I was first learning angular a long time
ago which I didn't I didn't learn it
well that I did a ton of work in the
disk folder and then it all went away
because the disk folder will get
rewritten you know when you when you go
to build it so that was very
disappointing when I was just beginning
and I it took me a long time just
dropped for a second so I was worried it
looks like it's back again so let's go
into our app folder
and I guess somebody of your index I
think I do have this Oh and just
everything is in the index page
all right so we'll scroll through and
I'll go through a little bit I want to
let you see my code so one of the the
major things about the stream that I
think is helpful is to let you all see
my mistakes and so this is an example of
I don't want to say mistakes but work
that I did two years ago that worked at
the time I was proud of it at the time
but now it's embarrassing to me
so you all a lot of you has seen my work
that I do now so this is a good
comparison of where I was two years ago
so this part up here is just doing some
checking for four different browsers and
basically telling people to update their
browser if they have an outdated browser
we're using a service called auth0 to
log people in so that's where all this
is coming in and then the rest here
should should look like basic HTML to
you all so here's our body tag right and
so now we have everything in here that
we'd have you know normally we have
headers you know unordered lists divs
are we have our nav component right so
now we're getting closer to where we
need to be so in our so here's our side
nav and here's our filters it says
filters go here
interesting alright I assumed that I
hard-coded these in but I guess I was a
little smarter than that and I'm I'm
actually getting categories from
WordPress and putting them in there it's
interesting okay just a quick overview
of the other things I have in here
before I try this other thing that might
make this a lot easier you can see we
have I have like this loading spinner
thing here and I use materialized CSS as
a framework so if you're familiar with
bootstrap materialise is the material
design version it's not it's not
affiliated with bootstrap but what
bootstrap does materialise does but with
material design styles so we've got the
spinner from there and we have some
containers where we're actually putting
in posts using all jQuery for that and
we have some modal's that open up with
some forms in them for people to submit
bulletin announcements yeah so there's
the markup it's not there's not a whole
lot with the markup because we're
loading so many things I mean really the
the modal's and the forms take up half
the markup on the page everything else
is being pulled in through with
JavaScript
all right so our app TAS and let's let's
shrink this up and let me make this a
bit bigger I'm afraid that might be too
small all right so our login stuff was
there we're doing some filtering based
on dates and I just want to show you
maybe one example of how I'm loading
things and I have some different buttons
that change the the layout
if you could see we're using fetch so I
just made a wrapper around a fetch go
get JSON all right but we were using the
fetch API so even back then but I
believe we were using polyfills with it
as well and so you see we're getting
data here from WordPress and then we're
pending in that this this actually is
right where we're gonna be working in so
you see we're getting categories we're
getting all the categories and we are
appending allies for each category so
some of the categories are already
hard-coded in there so you can see like
current bulletin take action and all are
hard-coded and then everything else gets
added after that it gets appended so you
can see you know here's those first
three and the rest of them get added on
now since I did it like this what this
means is I should be able to just change
the data in our WordPress installation
and then it should come over and
automatically be added into there so I
think we'll try that
okay I see so this was just starting
this so let me explain this a little bit
I got I don't know I guess it's not that
obvious if you're just starting out so
what we're doing here we're using jQuery
that's where this dollar sign comes in
and we're selecting the element on the
page with that has the ID of mobile demo
so that's kind of a bad idea probably
just had it left in there from some
example that I copied and then we can
use jQuery dot append to add something
to that element so what I'm doing here
is I'm using template literals so when
we have this little back tick that's
template literal syntax so when you do
that think of it like you're making a
string in JavaScript so if you were to
use a single or double quote same thing
except when you use template literal
syntax you can have multi-line strings
and it still works normally that will
give you problems but you can you can
also put in some little snippets of
JavaScript in the middle of this without
having to use like the plus sign to
concatenate it all together so it's
really great for templating which is
basically what I used here so instead of
using something like handlebars which
would have been really popular when I
did this as for a templating engine I
just made my own templates using
template literals and then you adding in
with jQuery to insert them into the page
so down here is where I actually get the
categories so you see we've we got the
data right and then we're doing a dot
then so right we get the data then we
want to pass the data in right so now
data is available to us under the name
the variable name of data right so
inside there we have a function where
we're taking data so we use we're using
for loop so we're gonna say let and let
is es6
yes 2015 so if you're used to using
they're so var you can use let in its
place and it has what's called block
scoping so you're you're less likely to
accidentally overwrite things if you use
let and Const all right so there's a
there's a lot of other good things in
there but I'm not gonna take time to
explain them all right now if you'd like
to know more about using let and cost
instead of there please ask it in the in
the live chat and I'll be happy to
explain it later on but this means
basically we're looping through every
category that's come to us and data
right and that's JSON format so JSON
format stops correct me if I'm wrong but
it's basically an array of objects so
it's gonna loop over each object and
it's gonna grab - we're calling it
category right so each one is going to
be category and we're using category ID
equals I must have made a variable
somewhere called categories all right
in any case when we get to here we are
appending on to the elements that has a
class of filters we're appending and so
this is I believe I dropped them we must
have a drop down somewhere as well so
we're adding all the categories category
ID category name and since we didn't I
didn't show the drop down let's just
skip that and we'll go to where we have
our mobile demo and we're appending
allies so for each category
we get the ID we get the slug in the
name from that data and we create an Li
with an a tag inside so the link tag
with this data all right and once that's
all created then okay we go on and we
add some other things let's see do we
yeah we do that quite a lot but we're
not gonna talk about that right now so
I'm not gonna go into that but that's
how we're building up the template we're
just taking that same mobile demo and
we're appending things on to it and you
can see this is how we're we're pulling
in JavaScript into our our string right
we have that template literal this is
obviously a string but then once we get
to here we have a dollar sign in a curly
bracket and then now we're back in
JavaScript land and we've actually put
some data in there so this part is not a
string and then we close that curly
bracket and we're back into string land
and you can see inside this we can even
use double quotes and it doesn't mess
anything up right just like you can use
single quotes inside of double quotes
and it doesn't mess things up okay so
let's let's do something now because I
think I've been explaining for quite a
while so let's make something happen I
am going to go
my other screen into WordPress let's see
there we go okay let me add on my other
screen all I'm doing is just logging
into a simple WordPress installation and
I'm just gonna add another category in
here and mm-hmm I don't remember what
that county we're supposed to be so let
me check my phone because I'm not
currently logged into my email on my
computer so it'll be faster to check out
my work email on my phone see the email
I got during yesterday's stream to see
what the category is supposed to be
called council minutes okay right so
let's add a category called council
minutes
all right so I've added a category
called Council minutes and
now I'm gonna empty I'm gonna empty the
cash so I have a lot of caching going on
so let me empty that first and then when
i refresh see if we have it now I also I
have it so much cash and going on so
let's inspect this and let's go into
application and we're gonna go in here
to local storage and you see we we have
some stuff huh maybe we don't have it
okay normally I was storing a lot of
stuff in local storage am i missing this
this is still a hard refresh Hey council
minutes we have council minutes but we
have no matching post yet so my timer
just went off when we come back I'm
gonna try to add a post here and see if
it will in fact show up here and where's
my timer I lost it
there we go so here oops
sure we'll take a short break when we
come back we'll do a little bit of
testing and then we'll go over how to
we'll go over how to save this commit
send the commit to github how to get our
dist folder ready and then how to push
that up to our production server so
we'll do all that on the stream so
you'll get the full range of from
cloning the repo all the way up to
updating your production server alright
so let me try to find where I left the
huff
hi Joe Matthews says Pomodoro Technique
25 525 yeah so I do I do 25 five and
then should I do for 25 sessions with
fives in between but then on that last
one I do a 10 10 minute break
realistically though it's it's rare that
I get for uninterrupted sessions and to
be able to even get to that 10 minute
break but that's how I use it
ma ma reuse Mar use says we be using
some kind of framework for this one
not exactly so in terms of the styles
we're using materialized CSS but I done
everything else from scratch using
jQuery so all the routing is jQuery like
I said the templating is done using
template literal syntax so it was way
more work I think that it had to be like
had I been had I known react at the time
I think I could have done better and
potentially done this faster in react so
if you want to see any of the code for
this let me know or if you want me to
explain how I did any of this let me
know I'll do my best to remember
Jason asked if I attended any web
conferences in Ohio
I have not attended any conferences in
Ohio yet so Jason's from Columbus yeah
I'd love to find out if they're any good
conferences going on and go because
they'd be pretty close I'm I've attended
conferences Syntex Khan in South
Carolina I attended that twice I spoke
at November in Nashville I will be at
the Google i/o conference in Pittsburgh
which is soon and I will be speaking at
Pittsburgh tech fest which obviously is
in Pittsburgh as well and I'm attending
revolution cough that's in Virginia
Beach and I believe that's next month so
those are where I'll be I frequently
apply to speak at different conferences
so I never I never know exactly what
conference I'll be at and so I find out
whether I'm accepted or not how I should
ask is that the same bulletin that was
have written in react yes yes it was and
I just never got a chance to keep
working on it because other projects
came up and we're still working on those
this Vishakha says i haven't attended a
live stream before what's the goal here
so yeah basically the goal is just I I
wanted to give everybody a glimpse of
what my day-to-day work is like
especially I wanted everyone to be able
to see how many mistakes I make and how
I try to work through that I especially
saw people who were beginners may feel
intimidated by watching a lot of the
normal tutorials because people don't
make mistakes and tutorials they're
edited as they should be right there to
the point but that's not really how it
works
at least not for me I mess up a lot and
sometimes I try things and it doesn't
work and we got a I just got to try
something else sometimes we don't have
time to do like the ideal solution so we
just do the good enough solution and
we're still able to you know release
websites that do their job they function
well and that people are happy with so
that's kind of the goal of it so it's
not exactly a tutorial although I do
hope people learn and I learned a lot
from you all so it's a little bit more
interactive than a tutorial but it
literally is really like my real life
job you know if I wasn't streaming this
I would be working on this right now for
my job so I don't rehearse things
because I want you to see as close as
possible what it's really like the only
difference is I don't narrate what I'm
doing to myself when I'm alone but other
than that it is pretty much exactly what
I would usually be working on and how I
would be working on it okay
let me I'm just gonna take note of where
I'm leaving off at and let's go back so
if I didn't get to your question yet I'm
sorry I will get to it after this next
Pomodoro session so let me let me go
through real quick I just want to see if
anybody wanted to see any part of the
code
okay let's go back in here now and oh I
know I I wanted to take one of the posts
and I want to add a category to it it's
updates move this over here okay let me
do a hard refresh yay okay so we can get
it to show up now I want to very quickly
get rid of that because that doesn't
look good when we have two categories
wonderful know if I update again great
no matching post all right so it works
right we get the functionality that we
want and
I'm gonna see I just I don't understand
why I had options for a drop-down in my
code but I don't know where that would
be here I'm thinking maybe maybe that
was something that I wanted to add and I
ended up not adding you see we're here
where it says filters
I do not understand see I mean there are
some parts of this code that I just I
have no idea what I did I don't remember
it this is a good case for making sure
to document what you do really well
I'm interested to see let's just take a
minute just to see if we can find this
filters oh of course it's gonna be like
this
okay so it looks like the only options
I'm seeing here let's go through find it
yeah okay we have years and that's it
okay so whatever I was trying to do here
evidently I I never did or it's just
somewhere where I have no idea where it
is so I'm just gonna leave that alone
that's sort of the the dangers of
dealing with this old code is of
accidentally changing some like right
now I could say all it looks like I'm
not using this at all maybe I'll just
delete it and then not realize that I
broke in something so I'm just gonna
leave it in there and I'm not gonna
attempt to refactor this because as I
mentioned before we have kind of halfway
rebuilt this in react so no no sense in
fixing this up so this works we've saved
it now let's go back to our terminal and
let's do let's update our disk and so
dis too short for distribution so
basically what it's going to do is go
through everything in this app folder
and it's going to basically well do what
we tell it to do and go so we have a few
things running in gulp we are going to
take all that es6 syntax and change it
to es 5 syntax so older browsers can
handle it it's going to automatically
take our sass and change it to regular
CSS and then it's also going to
automatically minify our code and I
don't remember I may actually have it
set up to concatenate some files as well
I can't remember if I did that on this
project ok so that's what it's going to
do all that for us and it's going to put
it into that dist folder and that's the
folder that we want to run on our server
so that when users go to our site you
know they're given these nice tidy
of minified code that is regular CSS and
es5 JavaScript's and it'll be usable by
as many people as possible so that's
what we're gonna do and in this case I
have it set up so that my command to run
all that is just go dist if you'd like
to see the gulp file where I set this
all up let me know I just know you know
gulp isn't as popular as once was so I'm
not sure if anybody is even interested I
just had a question gulp is more or less
an equivalent of webpack yeah it's whoa
what PAC is different but it does do a
lot of the things that gulp did so I
don't want to say that they are the same
exactly but for the purposes that people
use it for it's it's it is very similar
ok now let's do a git status to see
what's change actually I forgot we only
changed our package JSON didn't we
because we didn't have to make any
changes that is true okay well anyway I
still want to go through this process
just to show you how we would update it
so let's do that
so we're gonna first do a git add and
then we're going to do a git commit now
you can combine those steps if you want
to by doing commit am but in this case I
separated them out and we're just gonna
use em for message so now we can write
our message and we're going to say
update
package info and I'm gonna hit enter so
now we have our commit and now we can go
get push a lot of times you can just do
get pushing it will work but if you're
working on another branch for different
things you got to do a little bit more
so let's just do the full command now so
we're gonna go origin master so it'll
push master which we may only have one
branch actually right now so it doesn't
really matter but now everything is on
github so we can go back to that github
page and give it a little refresh and we
should see our update already yep 40
seconds ago we updated these two files
so there's our update and if this wasn't
a private repo you all could see that
and you know work on it on your own I
would say at least 90 percent of the
projects we work on are in public repos
so this is just one of those weird ones
where this was before I realized how to
use environment variables so there are
like API keys and stuff in this project
that's why it's private and now we're
gonna use flight plan and if you're not
familiar with flight plan let me just
explain it a bit flight plan will take
your code and copy it over so it will it
will look at your code it'll look at
your your get files to make sure of what
exactly changed and it will only copy
over those files that changed to your
server alright and then it will even run
commands on your server that you tell it
to to make sure that those files get in
the right folder so it helps with
deployment and it's it's kind of it's
very simple simple to setup so that's
what we're gonna we're gonna try I say
try because it doesn't always work
so let's do fly production
so the reason that we did our dissed and
committed that was because actually you
know what I didn't even need to do that
I don't know what I'm thinking I did
want to demonstrate it but actually I
don't we don't actually commit our
package.json we don't push that to the
server so this is just an example of
what we would do but the reason if
you're using flight plan you do need to
make sure that you are tracking your
dist folder and github which you don't
usually need to do but because flight
plan uses get to determine what has
changed if you're not tracking with get
your dist folder it won't it won't work
it won't know what's changed unless
somehow you build your stuff on the
server afterwards but at this particular
server that this is running on we don't
have access to node so we can't we can't
do n PM stuff on it so anyway basically
you know what it's done is it's
connected to our server it's moved the
folder to the root and then it's run
some commands right to copy our dist
folder over to our bulletin folder which
is this this is where that runs from
this is the home directory for a
bulletin site and that's it that's
that's everything that's done so this
could have been done by going into like
FileZilla and logging in to the server
and then manually copying and pasting
things or dragging and dropping things
you know which is fine it would take you
know an extra minute or so but this end
up this in the long run ends up being
much faster you know we just run it and
then check back a minute or two later
make sure everything works and I can run
let me go to the site Franciscan
University / bulletin you can try to go
there if you want but like ice
and the it's it's login only so you
won't be able to get in unless you're
you're a hacker or something and try to
get in in which case let me know how you
did it yeah so that works
let's check yep there should not be any
post so that's what we want there we go
just to show you some cool things that I
did with this you know and this is all
just jQuery we have updates for our
views we have a print view we have a
that I get rid of classic view I think I
did I used to have a classic view but I
think I got rid of it it was it was kind
of a joke because I made it look just
like the old Microsoft Word bulletin
that everybody got emailed we actually
we have a live search feature so if I
type in the week stuff we can get you
know the same thing so it does the
search so there's a lot of the same
functionality that we have with some of
the react stuff we've been doing we have
it here as well oh that's the little UI
bug isn't it interesting
Wow
okay so I don't know what I did but
evidently if you click the right things
you will mess up the z-index of these
okay and this is just you know regular
form just do like a submit via fetch so
we don't get a page refresh or anything
and this is an upload the file uploads
on the back end or just with a basic PHP
file upload that I that I wrote yeah we
have some emails get that are
automatically sent and I believe by
using Google I was using Google Docs for
that I think I ended up switching and
using SendGrid or something like that so
anyway so that's it let me check my time
I think I probably almost out of time
for this Pomodoro session a lot of ten
minutes left
all right let's I'm gonna go back to the
questions see what questions you all
have you know I
it's basically mission accomplished for
this one it ended up being a lot easier
than I thought it would be I didn't
think it would be that hard but I
basically I built it the way I thought
it should be built so in my mind I'm
thinking like why did I hard code this
stuff I should have just made it
automatically pull from WordPress that's
what I thought before I looked at the
project then when we looked at and I
realized that is exactly what I did I
thought hey I'm I'm pretty smart guy two
years ago so I did take the time to do
that
all right I don't remember where I left
off okay inna says Jesse how was your
weekend
not bad I went to a wedding and that was
fun
but I wasn't feeling really well so I
was super tired so the kids had a lot of
fun you know dancing and eating lots of
cookies and stuff got to see a lot of my
family so that was that was fun
and then all the all the little ones so
all my my cuz
are all having kids now and they're all
around the same age so it was really
cool you know I've all these little ones
running around at the wedding and
playing together and so that was really
fun but unfortunately I didn't get to
stay as long as I wanted to because I
was just so exhausted but yeah it was um
it was a good time good time this
weekend thanks for asking and how was
your weekend
chyna I'm trying to scroll down and find
questions michael says you were looking
for ways to make your streams better
katie is a step in that direction
yeah katie is awesome I don't know she'd
be comfortable being on the stream all
the time though but actually let me know
what would you all like it if I actually
had someone in here maybe someone even
who's learning how to code that would be
here with me and would ask questions and
I don't know I that's definitely
possible I mean I have another chair so
I can't have at least one other person
and yeah if you think that's something
that you might like seeing I'll
definitely try it out I know there are
there are some students who may be
interested and some of my co-workers who
may be interested as well if I'm
streaming from home I might be able to
get my wife to do it she is learning to
code as well she usually doesn't like to
be on camera but maybe she'll do it
let's see
Vishakha says thanks so the stream
should be watched in continuation she
was saying thanks to Phoenix so this
live stream should be watched in
continuation you know they can but
they're quite a few of them so it may be
really difficult if you do try to watch
a lot of them I definitely recommend
watching them on to time speed because
it's just so much to get through so
don't don't feel like you you have to go
through step by step to understand
things there's I don't think you do
necessarily and I think it's just way
too much material for a person to
reasonably be expected to go through I
mean we have almost a year of I need to
look up when my first live stream was
because we're coming up on a year of
live streams so it might be fun to
actually acknowledge that when the day
comes if I haven't already missed it but
there you know well over I believe a
hundred hours of live streams for sure
I have my cooks as well is that on Gia's
Geocities no it's not that old how many
people had an old website on Anzio
cities it was the other one like Angel
Fire how many had a site on one of those
like free hosting plans back in the day
I definitely did Harshit says this has
century air as well saw the Raven skip
tag
yeah yeah so I do have some error stuff
error reporting with century on this so
I was pretty thoughtful about all what I
was doing on this I'm I mean I I liked
it when it came out but you know I I
just think I don't know I've come a long
way coding so there's so many things
that I think now like that could have
done better but you know at the time it
was it was probably the best thing I'd
ever made hi Joseph the site looks great
yeah it's style wise it's not really
that far off from a lot of the newer
things that we've been doing
Don Xavier says hey and we all have our
treasure trove of depression code it's
implied and nice to take a walk on
memory lane sometimes yeah yeah it is
fun it's fun to check out the the old
code
hey John Hanson's here hey John how's it
going
alright Michael said the I thought of
was relatively new to like the four of
loops so you were forward-thinking even
then yeah I mean I did use some newer
stuff and I had the the babble like
transpiling set up so that I could use
that John says is it worth it the
reconfigure site that uses jQuery and
then change it all to JavaScript I guess
it depends on what the site is what your
goal is for the site hmm sorry I'm a
little sorry I'm trying to quit drinking
coffee for like a week just so like try
to reset my tolerance because I was
getting to the point where I could drink
coffee all day and still be tired you
know I could drink an espresso and go to
sleep so I think that's a problem so
just cut it off I am quite sleepy let's
see yeah so John I don't know I mean if
for this site in particular if I wasn't
already halfway through rebuilding it
again in react it might be worth it to
try to change it to use vanilla
JavaScript but I don't know I mean it
works right now with the jQuery so is it
if it's working and it's quick it
performs well and it gets the job done
you know maybe there's not really much
reason to want to change it from jQuery
to vanilla JavaScript I mean there's
still a lot of jQuery out there and
there are a lot of jobs for being able
to use jQuery like there has to be right
because so many sites use it so not that
there's your I'm not trying to say that
jQuery is wrong in every situation I
definitely don't want to use it with
Reax
but with other sites you know it's it's
a valid option
Harshit said what is the need of push if
you added the post in WordPress yep you
were entirely right Hart said I did not
need to push anything the only thing
that we actually changed was that
package JSON file so in terms of
functionality I did not need to push
anything glad I made those changes to
package JSON though because I did want
to go through the process of it at least
for those of you that are learning it
Jason said I saw one of your sites was
for college in Ohio assumed you might
have been from Ohio oh yeah I currently
live in Steubenville Ohio I actually
live like right outside of City Limits
but it's still the address is still
Stephen go I am from West Virginia
though right at the very like
northernmost part of West Virginia and
near Pittsburgh but I I now live just
across the border in Ohio Francesca says
what no talking to yourself
yeah all right full disclosure here I do
sometimes talk to myself when I'm coding
but it's usually when I get upset and
then I say things that I might not say
around my children that's when I will
talk to myself or if I do something
really awesome and it works then I may
like have exclamations of joy and
usually you like jump up out of my seat
I throw my headphones down and I like go
out the door or look for somebody who I
can tell and usually I find somebody who
I'm like trying to explain what I did
with the code and they have no idea what
I'm talking about there but they're
usually really awesome about it and
congratulate me anyway
michael says you don't talk to yourself
when working on a problem that's when I
work the best because of the stares from
co-workers it's why I'm better at humor
huh but because of the same some
co-workers that's why I'm better working
my own yeah you know what you are right
whenever I'm streaming and I get to talk
through step by step what I'm trying to
do I often find like problems in my
logic or in my code so maybe I should
start talking to myself more even when
I'm not streaming that might not be a
bad idea I have had my kids like sitting
with me when I'm coding before and I'll
try to talk it through with them and
it's helped me and I found like errors
that way
Oh Michael says just found out about the
bracket pair colorizer extension 4 vs
code oh yeah you know what I heard about
that that's a really cool plugin so if
you've ever tried to figure out what's
going on with your brackets like which
brackets go together and if you've
missed one or not that can definitely be
very helpful
oh yeah Harish it says I got in already
yeah you did
I don't remember how you did it the or
[ __ ]
and I remember I wasn't that worried
about it because we were gonna switch it
over to react and then we didn't have
time
Phoenix says oh yes totally so I had
asked like would it be cool to have
other people on the stream like right
here with me in my office if Phoenix
said yes totally you can also do pair
programming it'll add a whole new
dimension to these streams yeah I hadn't
thought about that I guess that would be
cool
I'm gonna yeah I'm definitely gonna
think about that I'll talk to some
people around here to see if I can get
somebody like physically in the office I
don't talk to my wife see if she's
interested and then you know maybe I can
do some remote pair programming as well
Vishakha says new coder seems like a
pretty good idea but you did a great job
of answering questions oh cool thank you
yeah cool yeah I mean most likely most
of the streams will still just be me cuz
it's a lot to ask for somebody to take
this much time out of their day but you
know maybe occasionally I could you know
have somebody else on the stream
and it says my weekend was great I
walked in the forest with my family
Oh awesome you know and I think I saw
your your Instagram post a picture of
the forest it was really beautiful
cool thanks for sharing
okay Phoenix is May 3rd 2017 was the
first dream ok cool off to see cuz I did
start streaming on my own channel first
but if we want to count like the first
free code camp stream you know maybe
we'll do that cuz if I check my we may
already be passed the date when I
started on my own channel that's cool I
need to check and see how many videos
I've done and like how many hours has
been because I have no idea John Hanson
says I had an old Yahoo website CSS
tables anyone oh yeah for sure
remember doing the layout and tables
iframes John Hanson says so gamer noob
says if it isn't broken right like if
isn't broken don't fix it John Hanson
says true though I'm not against jQuery
I do find reading JavaScript code it
makes more sense to me than trying to
read some old jQuery code I've written
yeah that's that's true I mean if you do
write in jQuery anybody it's not
familiar with jQuery may not be able to
read it and I before even just a few
years ago like everybody at least I was
familiar with jQuery it seemed like even
if people were against jQuery at least
they still were aware of it and knew
about it but it seems like newer devs
especially like if they're coming
through boot camps if the boot camp just
goes like vanilla JavaScript and then
straight into react or something like
that you know they may have never been
exposed to any jQuery and will have no
idea because it definitely is is
different you know you try to make
things happen on a screen or buttons
function and stuff and react it's a
whole different mindset
then the way you do it in in jQuery so
you know I think like moving forward if
that's still the case and it goes like
that where you have people just
completely skipping the jQuery because
it I don't know it seems to me like it
used to be the way the tutorials always
went though at least the ones that I did
you know a couple years ago where you
learn HTML CSS then you jumped into
jQuery and after jQuery then you got
into more like vanilla JavaScript stuff
so people were learning jQuery first
just to be able to get some some sites
like working so you know now it's I just
I don't see that as much anymore with
some of the newer boot camps and
tutorials John Hanson says talking to
yourself is a sign of high intelligence
or so I keep telling myself I like that
okay
Harshit I see your message about
authentication and stuff so just maybe
if you get time let me know like in a DM
or something
or if you already sent it to me just
tell me and I'll try to look for it
Vishakha says what kind of topics do you
speak in the conference's so let me
think I have done a talk like on my live
streaming so at at November my talk was
about my experience and live-streaming
and like the amazing community that's
been built up around the stream and how
it's changed my life as a developer I
mean really it's changed my life in
general not just as a developer you know
being able to you know hang out with you
all and and just share experiences it's
not just coding experiences but being
able to share things about my mental
health and my family and just you know
everything and learning about you all
like I mean there's also there's a lot
of interaction that even goes on the on
the stream
you know on on Instagram and Twitter and
you know different social media networks
even through email you know where I get
to communicate with with a lot of you
all and yeah so that was my talk and
that one is if you want to watch that
talk it's on my youtube channel the link
to my channel is in the description so
it's it was actually live streams from
my channel so you can check that out if
you want I'm giving a talk I just did a
talk for the moms can code virtual
summit and that talk I believe is only
available if you're a member of moms can
code so I'm not sure how much it costs
to be a member so I I can't say now
would it would it cost but if you're
already a member you want to be a member
or you can check out that talk that talk
was about my experience of coming from a
background of being in business and then
being a teacher and then transitioning
into you know being a web developer and
kind of like what I went through and
that was like I tried to keep the talk
really short and I have a lot of time
for question and answers and there were
so many questions that ended up being
you know really good and I was
interesting talk because it was you know
mostly women in the audience I think
they were like a hundred and sixty or so
women so usually I think my audience for
the streams are mostly men so that was
really actually interesting to like what
kind of questions I got and so I did
like that and I'm gonna speak in at the
Pittsburgh tech fest I'm gonna speak
about building a using WordPress as a
content management system for react and
using graph QL and Apollo with that so
that are project five that we've been
working on it's basically going to be a
mini demo like stripped down to the
basics of what we've been doing there oh
cool Francesca says mom's can code is
only fifty dollars a year if you get
paid for a whole year upfront
five dollars a month okay so that's
that's pretty for at least four for the
United States that's pretty affordable
awesome thanks for that and Francesca I
see it says you got to get your kids
from date daycare I said thanks Jesse
talk to you later you're welcome thank
you so much for watching and yeah go and
get your kids and let's see I lost my
place oh my oh hey all of us here all
the first says hey Oliver house how you
doing okay michael says actual serious
question for once do you have a base
package.json file you use that has all
your usual modules actually yeah for my
old like jQuery projects and just you
know basic websites I do and that's
that's pretty much this package JSON
file so this one was frequently copied
where I have gulp and you can see I have
babble so I can use the newer version
versions of JavaScript I minify my HTML
I have a package you know to minify
images this inject lets me put like
analytics code in after the fact
obviously we're going to minify CSS this
lets me use sass uglify is minifying our
JavaScript on cache basically adds like
you can see it on the screen it adds
like a string of numbers to the end of
your file names so that browsers don't
keep old versions of your code cache
like if you just name your your
JavaScript app KS it might be
aggressively cached by browser and so
you your users might not get the update
the browser will just keep using the
cached version and it's the same thing
for CSS and then use men let's see your
places not optimized scripture style
sheets
instead of HTML files I had to use them
for something oh okay all right that
that basically takes like my development
site uses references to the unmodified
[Music]
untransparent of my JavaScript my CSS
and then when it goes to disk it
automatically changes the references so
that it starts referencing the optimized
files in the disk folder so that's what
that does
so this is my base thing it automates a
lot and it lets me get started really
quickly I haven't used this in a while
because we've been working with react
stuff and I have a whole different set
of things for react but this is really
helpful if you just want to make a basic
like one pager or just something really
simple and you don't think you know you
need to use a larger framework for I you
know I recommend this and I'm sure all
these are out of dates so there's
probably a lot of updating that could
take place since this was from two years
ago but I probably have this available
on some of the other projects so if like
if you wanted to copy this from github
just check out some of the other you
know jQuery one-page projects and you
know feel free to use that if you'd like
Vishakha says any tips for submitting
proposals for conferences I'll try to
get some tips but to be honest with you
I've I feel like I'm pretty new at
submitting the conference's I dev I get
rejected by most of the conference's I
submit to so I don't know if I'm doing a
good job at it or not but I will say
submit when you are submitting I my
strategy right now is I have a talk
that's more like they consider it as a
soft skills talk right so I talk more
about my
five coding in my experience there and
then I have a talk that's more technical
so when I submit I always submit
multiple proposals depending on what a
conference wants because sometimes a
conference you know they may want
something that's not so technical where
they you know so you don't always know
what they want ahead of time so I like
to submit at least two and you
definitely want like you want your title
and like the beginning of your
description to grab their attention you
know like be honest about the title but
definitely don't be afraid to have it be
something eye-catching like my November
talk that I did get selected for the
title of the talk was how live coding
changed my life so it's kind of dramatic
right I mean it's it's true it's I'm not
lying about that but it's definitely a
dramatic title so that kind of would
stand out to somebody that maybe is
getting a ton of talks that you're
saying like I don't know like optimize
you like your webpack build or something
you know really like kind of more bland
things so that's pretty much my only
advice I really ought to to study up
more on how to do proper proposals and I
just you know how does you just get busy
with everything you know a family and
work and everything and sometimes stuff
like that just gets pushed to the side
and you just do the best you can I do
recommend going to pay per call io paper
called IO has a bunch of conferences
there it'll tell you info about the
conferences you can get notified when
new conference calls for paper oak calls
for papers open up and you can save your
proposals and then just auto submit them
so you don't have to keep typing all the
same stuff out again so try you know
check that site out that's I mean get
PAP er CA ll do
andrew says is it okay for a front-end
dev to learn back-end as well all for
sure for sure yeah I think it's good I
mean I think it's good for people who do
back-end to learn a little front-end and
front-end people to learn a little bit
of back-end because sometimes they they
bleed over into each other like I'm sure
you all seen during this you know during
my streams sometimes we do a lot of
back-end stuff because you know although
I'm a front-end developer by title
realistically I do what I have to do to
get projects done so depending on where
you work you may need to do that as well
if you're working on a project like on
your own you're gonna have to do
everything regardless of what you
consider yourself front-end or back-end
you're gonna have to do that work so at
this point I mean honestly I like I've
applied for and been offered jobs for a
full-stack because I I can do that so
when I go into an interview I say yes my
title was front-end developer but we
don't have a you know a back-end
developer that works on our projects
with me so like realistically I am full
stack in what I have to do Michael says
if there was only a way for for me to
see that talk in Pittsburgh about graph
QL react Apollo hopefully that'll be
streamed somewhere yeah I don't know
what the plans are in terms of recording
but I'll probably ask the organizers if
there's any way like if they're not
gonna record or stream it oh ask them if
I can and then I'll just get somebody
I'll have to get somebody to to stream
it maybe I'll find somebody in the
audience to hold my phone and stream it
and I don't think my wife has tickets to
that one maybe I'll see if she wants to
get tickets if she doesn't and I should
come with me
she's my wife's actually the one that
got me tickets to the Google i/o
conference which is really cool
de veg says can I please know what
exactly web developers do and what kind
of work is assigned to them alright so
I'm gonna be very like general in this
because there's a wide range of
different types of things web developers
do and how they go about doing it but
basically a web developer would be
assigned work to either build or update
a website or web app and it would be
their job to make that happen
and there's a variety of different
technologies that they would use and
programming languages that they could
use on the front end side of things
they're definitely going to be using
HTML CSS and JavaScript that's pretty
standard but on the back end there's
much more variety in what they could use
they could use JavaScript it could be
PHP Python I mean for pro I don't I
don't really know I've never used
anything other than JavaScript and PHP
for back-end but there's a variety you
know we did do some c-sharp now I think
about it so c-sharp there there's a lot
of different things that you can use
there so it's hard to say for sure what
they're gonna be doing but that's
basically what what they what they will
do so if you have any like more specific
stuff I could give you get into more
specifics but you know it's just such a
broad thing that it's hard to say for
sure what anyone web developer would be
doing and that's it that's the end of
the live chat so unless any other
questions sneaked in there in the next
minute or so I think I'm gonna wrap
things up and thank you all so much for
watching and for all the awesome
questions and comments it was really fun
today hopefully you all you know likes
me going back and doing this you know
sometimes it's nice to have a little
break from the project we've been
working on for what it seems like so
long so if if you
really hate when I do this kind of thing
let me know if you really like it let me
know if you don't say anything at all
I'll just assume like it was okay um and
I I you know I'm not gonna do this all
the time but occasionally it might be
nice so let's say it was a Wednesday all
right I'll be in the office again on
Thursday I should be able to stream you
think I don't know what my schedules
like Thursday so I can't I don't know
when exactly I'll be able to stream so
I'll put something on Twitter and
probably on Instagram and then if you
turn on your notifications for this
YouTube channel the free code camp
channel you should get a notification as
well so if you're active on Twitter
Instagram you know maybe think about
following me so you can get updates on
what I'm going to stream as well links
are in the description for those
accounts so should be back oh we had one
more question Audion you got it in there
just in time can you tell me one thing
to start so I can do freelance if you
want to do freelance stuff honestly
depending on what year you're into I
would say like start with your local
businesses and I've I've never done this
but I've heard people have success with
this they actually built a website for
local business before they get a job
like a demo website and then show that
to them and say look how nice this
website is it'll bring you you know
whatever new customers it'll solve this
problem for you or something like that
and then you can potentially get them as
a client and even if you don't get them
as a client you have something in your
portfolio so you said I haven't used
that in particular but I've I've heard
other people who have been successful
with with that strategy so you may want
to give that a try and Michael says by
the way if you get sinking into the
conference in New Orleans I'd be okay
with that yeah you know what I'm
actually not going to go to that
so I ended up after I looked at what the
talks would be I realized you know what
this is geared towards like upper
management and not really towards
developers so I decided like you know
what although I got free tickets I'd
still have to pay for my own flight and
my hotel so or my my employer would
either way I would rather spend that
money going to a conference that I would
get more out of so there was a lot of
really cool stuff about that conference
but I don't think it would help me that
much professionally so I decided against
it but it really it would have been
really cool I think I wanted to see New
Orleans more than I actually wanted to
see the speakers at the conference so I
just couldn't couldn't really justify
that all right so now I'm done with the
questions I'm gonna get out of here for
real now thank you so much and have a
great day I'll see y'all tomorrow